I brought you the gift yeah I know David
Bowie has bigger balls than me so
something has turned up that turns up
every couple of years and that is word
of a plan follow-up remake reimagining
thing related to the Jim Henson classic
labyrinth now if this at all seems like
an odd one for me to talk about and
maybe a little out of my wheelhouse
I'll just throw it out there labyrinth
is my favorite fantasy film ever yes
more than Lord of the Rings now what the
word is is that something that to the
best of my knowledge hasn't happened
before in the various times that it's
like been come up a rumor that somebody
was working on a follow-up to labyrinth
and that is they have a director that I
don't think has happened before or it
hasn't happened in a very long time
there have been producers who have
talked about it they've been writers on
it I mean there was a writer on it like
a little over a year ago who you know
was very emphatic that what she was
writing was not a remake it was a
follow-up now she is not on this current
project at least I didn't see her name
associated with it so the name now is
fede alvarez and he is a director of not
a ton of stuff but he had directed the
Evil Dead remake and he directed don't
breathe I haven't seen don't breathe I
have seen the Evil Dead remake so I feel
like I've got a kind of general sense of
the guy or at least sort of his
potential
apparently he's also working on the
script he's got a regular writing part
or saying guy he worked on the script
for don't breathe with now initially
that it seems like an odd pick a guy who
at this point is known as a horror movie
director but of course one of the
aspects of for particularly more
supernatural horror like Evil Dead was
is to really sell and get your audience
invested in an unreal scenario and
that's a skill set that lends itself to
fantasy as well now I'd like to think
they're not gonna go soup
dark fantasy because labyrinth isn't
especially now of course the big
elephant in the room if they're going to
do anything related to labyrinth and and
worm right now as I understand is that
they are still talking follow-up of some
kind it may be not necessarily a direct
sequel like it may not deal with the
same character but you know some sort of
follow-up set in that world dealing with
that mythology and not a remake which is
good that said what is the defining
characteristic of labyrinth it's jerath
it's David Bowie and thankfully work
right now
the gate can always change but word
right now is that they are not using the
character of the goblin king they are
not going to recast that part but if I'm
being completely honest without that
character and without David Bowie
playing that character I don't know how
much I want to say I mean I I like
everything about labyrinth I like the
world that it's set in but he really was
the hook especially initially he's one
of my favorite villains and I could
seriously I could ramble for probably
the next 20 minutes just talking about
all the aspects of that character that I
loved even as a kid he was what really
drew me in so lacking him kind of it
just makes it makes it a harder sell for
me now if I remove my love of him from
it is this a world a setting that allows
for other stories sure it's a bonkers
world there I'm sure there are bajillion
stories you could tell in this and if
they're gonna do something like that I
hope that it's not in terms of the
general plot structure too much of a
retread I figure they're probably still
gotta have you know a person probably a
young person they'll probably aim it at
the same family age range but the you
know someone who is pulled into the
world of the labyrinth and has to find
their way through it out of it whatever
because when you have a world this nuts
you kind of want that audience surrogate
characters someone who can react to all
that stuff and kind of the way that we
would without that you run the risk of
the film just being alienate
kind of holding its audience at a
distance but in terms of the sorts of
things that could be right and they I
mean that's sort of where I land on this
I get I get very nervous because I would
love to see more in that world but when
I say that I mean I want to see more of
that world I don't want to see a new
character just running into the same
characters I don't want somebody else to
get stuck in the oubliette and get the
helping hands or run into the worm I
mean I'm not saying don't we I mean have
a few throats or didymus in there you
know something a little thing but I
don't I don't want to retread I want I
want an expansion but and honestly even
that is a risky thing to do because for
me a big part of what I love about
labyrinth is the traditional fairy tale
feel and what I mean by that is it
doesn't feel the need to over explain
itself there's no house or wise or
here's the logic behind it no this is
just what happens why is that what
happens because the magic world that's
why that in you'd I love the that sort
of whimsy that you get from why is it
like this just because well how does
that work it just does and I I enjoy
that that that fires my imagination more
than something that is overly explained
in explicit detail which is one of the
reasons I didn't really care for sort of
ancillary and extra stuff that was done
around the world of labyrinth like there
was a there was kind of a sequel of kind
of a manga and I read I read a little of
it it just didn't grab because I'm
watching it like explain more about
jerath and about his history I'm like I
want to know I liked trying to come up
with my own notions and my own ideas of
why he is the way he is being told
explicitly kind of takes some of the
magic away for me at least and I think
it's gonna be really hard to revisit
this world without giving in to the
temptation to add in a lot of those
explanations way personally kind of
would prefer that the Henson Company do
in terms of this property is do more
things like Mirrormask which I do was is
not a film that people talk about much
critics didn't really
I liked mayor masks a lot I don't love
it as much as the original labyrinth but
it's very much in that vein it kind of
takes that template but is using a
different world but it is still that you
know young girl got in this insane world
can she get out and I kind of like the
idea of a spiritual follow-up to
labyrinth more than a direct one even
though as I said I really like that
world and I would like to see that world
again and I mean I should go without
saying that you do puppet saying you do
real practical effects for pretty much
everything cuz I don't it won't feel
like labyrinth I've just I've got that
I've just overall I've got that push and
pull I think that most people have when
something they really care about is
getting either made into a movie for the
first time or is getting remade or
folded up on her or whatever because I'm
getting that that push pull of that yes
more of this thing and go God don't
screw it up so this is one that I at
least will be keeping a pretty close eye
on I don't know if I'll do too many
videos leading up to it and there's the
distinct possibility the whole thing
could fall apart as I said there have
there's been news sporadically for a lot
of years about some sort of follow-up to
labyrinth and it's it's fallen but it's
been in development health for ever's
and got same with the Dark Crystal
sequel for that matter although that
makes me wonder if they do the labyrinth
up and it works would they finally pull
the trigger on the Dark Crystal sequel
and honestly I think that one would make
more sense in terms of of a project to
do and I say that I actually don't like
the Dark Crystal as much as I like
labyrinth but I feel like that's a world
that lends itself more to telling more
stories in it and there wouldn't be as
much of a need to retread the same
ground as I fear a labyrinth follow-up
would be but that's sort of where I'm at
with all of this do you care about the
original labyrinth what does this news
do for you whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a list
the council eeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]